[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
le jeune homme peut ouvrir cette photo
s'appelle sera vrai scoop tas il avait
22 ans il était analyste pour la banque
d'affaires goldman sachs à san francisco
et la nuit du 17 avril 2015
il appelle ses parents en pleine nuit ça
fait deux jours que je ne dors pas c'en
est trop j'ai une présentation
importante à rendre pour demain mon
manager est en colère je vais encore
passé la nuit seul au bureau
la même nuit à 4 heures du matin il
retrouvait défénestré sur un parking
près de son immeuble
48 heures sans dormir une pression et un
stress qui le pousse à se défenestrer
comment en sommes-nous arrivés jusque là
comment en sommes nous arrivés à
sacrifier notre sommeil à ce point et
bien cela dure depuis plusieurs
décennies au même titre que la cigarette
dans les années 90 était un symbole de
virilité de succès la privation de
sommeil chronique est devenu les
dernières décennies une forme de
productivité d'accomplissement personnel
comme le disait gordon gecko dans les
années 80 l'argent ne dort jamais tout a
changé depuis que thomas edison qui
considérait d'ailleurs que le sommeil
était une véritable perte de temps
invente alan poul nos nuits se sont
électrisé la société s'est
industrialisée puis numériser le
business mondial est en marche
24 heures sur 24 ce qui laisserait
croire que les petits dormeurs ont
d'ailleurs un avantage concurrentiel
certain c'est ce qu'aime pensait le
président américain donald trump qui est
extrêmement fier de ses quatre heures de
sommeil par nuit
alors petit aparté un dormir quatre
heures par nuit n'a jamais aidé à
prendre de grandes décisions en tout cas
j'ai pas mis la main sur cette
publication on réalise
et les personnes qui ont cette capacité
génétique représente 0 % la population
désolé pour nous autres le commun des
mortels la privation de sommeil
chronique dont d'ailleurs une personne
sur trois souffre dans cette salle a des
conséquences désastreuses sur la santé
et les performances aux dents court
terme les performances mentales les
performances physiques et dans le long
terme notre santé le mauvais sommeil est
corrélée avec le diabète avec
l'hypertension avec l'obésité avec
alzheimer avec parkinson avec les
maladies mentales
bien dormir n'est pas un luxe mais une
nécessité absolue
pendant notre sommeil nous avons un tas
de mécanismes biologiques et
physiologiques absolument critique qui
ont lieu nous consolidons notre mémoire
nous récupérons la journée nous
régénérer nos cellules nous éliminons
des déchets comme par exemple la bêta
amyloïde la bêta amyloïde c'est ce qui
est responsable en cas de trop grande
accumulation dans le cerveau de la
maladie d'alzheimer
et pourtant en soixante dix ans nous
avons perdu 60 nuits par an un fait
marquant un adolescent les années 50 un
adolescent pour qui le sommeil est
absolument critique pour son
développement
dormez en moyenne 9 heures par nuit
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 70 % à
dormir moins de cinq heures par nuit
et malheureusement pour nous les
solutions pour nous aider à mieux dormir
au quotidien sont peu nombreuses et pas
vraiment convaincante
il y à la plus communément utilisé les
somnifères ou les benzodiazépines ont
d'ailleurs nous avons un triste record
de consommation en france
première chose les somnifères n'aide pas
à mieux dormir
deuxième chose ils ont des conséquences
désastreuses sur notre santé l'épidémie
de mauvais sommeil est devenue une
problématique un problème de santé
majeur
à tel point que cela a motivé les
dernières décennies des travaux de
recherche à un effort de recherche sans
précédent sur le sommeil il ya quelques
semaines le prix nobel de médecine a
d'ailleurs été décerné à une équipe de
trois scientifiques pour leurs
découvertes sur les principes derrière
notre horloge biologique
la logique c'est ce qui fait que nous
sommes réveillés la journée nous
endormons soir avoir décerné la plus
grande récompense scientifiques à des
travaux de recherche sur le sommeil est
sans doute la plus belle preuve que le
sommeil plus que jamais est devenu un
élément critique majeure et central de
nos sociétés alors la recherche foisonne
de concept de principe d'innovation
d'idées pour nous aider à mieux dormir
et ce de manière non invasive mais
pourquoi dans mon nous toujours aussi
mal et bien parce que pour comprendre et
agir sur notre sommeil
il faut comprendre et agir sur notre
cerveau et tout cela est extrêmement
contraignant compliqué et coûteux
aujourd'hui par exemple si vous souffrez
d'un double de sommeil vous allez vous
rendre dans une clinique un centre
spécialisé
on va vous équiper d'un dispositif qu'on
appelle une polysomnographie qui coûte
environ 20000 euros
l'installation par l'équipe va durer une
heure l'analyse est donné le matin va
durer deux heures et la nuit aura coûté
environ 1000 euros
à l'opposé voici l'un des utilisateurs
portant notre technologie
le bandeau en place dans 90% des cas
l'appareil de mesure clinique et coûte
500 euros l'installation se fait en dix
secondes
l'analyse se fait automatiquement le
matin en une minute et la nuit a coûté
zéro puisque vous avez dormi dans votre
lit et bien c'est en regardant ces
chiffres que nous est venue une idée
pourquoi ne pas créer le premier
laboratoire des portes et de recherche
sur le sommeil
eh bien je suis très heureux d'annoncer
ce soir à tedx paris que nous nous
lançons dès demain les inscriptions pour
ce programme de recherche inédit
merci
les utilisateurs volontaires pourront
participer au programme
ils recevront en avant première des
nouvelles idées des nouveaux concepts
des nouvelles fonctionnalités non
invasive évidemment pour les aider à
mieux dormir
en échange ils nous donneront plus de
donner plus d'informations sur leur
ressenti par exemple en journée et nous
analyserons en continu les données en
provenance des milliers
d'enregistrements quotidien nous
pensions que 90% des cas de mauvais
sommeil pourrait être résolue par des
techniques non invasives et pour que ça
fonctionne il faut imaginer ses
fonctionnalités il faut les développer
il faut les implémenter il faut les
tester
il faut y tirer dessus ce que la
recherche classique ne permet absolument
pas de faire
derrière ce programme se cache
l'ambition de développer et de tester de
nouvelles techniques non invasives pour
nous aider à regagner un sommeil de
bonne qualité et ce sur une échelle
géographique et temporelle sans
précédent notre premier programme durera
un mois
sur 1000 participants on va le lancer en
janvier avec comme objectif de générer
20 00h à titre d'exemple un essai
clinique traditionnelle sur le sommeil
comme on a pu faire dans le passé coûte
environ 50000 euros
la durée 6 mois sur 25 participants pour
générer à la fin 75 nuit ce processus va
être six fois plus rapide pour générer
300 fois plus de données et nous aura
coûté dix fois moins cher
l'objectif à long terme de ce programme
est bien évidemment de nous aider à
développer un ensemble de
fonctionnalités non invasive pour nous
aider à récupérer un sommeil de bonne
qualité et ainsi présenter une
alternative aux somnifères
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là derrière
toutes les données que nous allons
générer il ya là une valeur inestimable
nous allons avoir accès chaque nuit
entre 7 heures et 9 heures
d'enregistrement physiologiques de très
haute qualité
l'activité cérébrale le rythme cardiaque
la fréquence respiratoire
eh bien nous pensons que nous serions
capables dans ces données de détecter
des marqueurs qui nous permettrait de
détecter et de prédire des mois voire
des années avant l'apparition des
symptômes
certaines pathologies alors bien
évidemment on pense aux pathologies
neurodégénératives ou pas aux
pathologies cardiovasculaires aux
maladies mentales puisque c'est celle ci
qui ont une corrélation avec notre
mauvais sommeil
effectivement s'il ya une corrélation
entre les deux mesures et le sommeil de
manière précise pourrait nous aider à
remonter assez pathologique à
l'idéologie transhumanistes prône la
fusion entre nos corps biologique et la
technologie avancée avec comme but
d'augmenter nos performances physiques
ou cognitive c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque
chose d'assez sexy attirant intéressant
mais il faut bien comprendre que c'est
cette même mentalité cette même
idéologie qui nous a poussé les
dernières décennies à sacrifier notre
sommeil la recherche de performance et
de productivité à tout prix n'est pas
sans conséquences sur notre santé
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus anxieux
nous sommes plus stressés il ya plus de
maladies mentales il ya plus de maladies
neurodégénératives il faut que cela
cesse il faut que nous prenions action
chercheurs médecins ingénieurs école
entreprise évidemment dormeur résoudre
l'épidémie globale du mauvais sommeil
est une priorité absolue
il faut tout ce que nous ralentissions
et cela commence dès ce soir
merci
[Applaudissements]